about to answer some of your most unique
medical questions you've got some good
ones for me today huge thanks to
Walgreens for sponsoring this video
let's get started
what's a subject you wish your
professors had spent more time focusing
on when they were teaching you in med
school okay
hotly contested subject the one thing I
would add a monthly improv class where
you have to live in the moment without
preparation just be there be a person
speak your feelings just yell at each
other
does drinking the recommended amount of
water per day throughout the day have
the same impact on your body as if you
just chugged it all in one or two
sittings it's not the same your body can
only absorb so much water and if it
doesn't absorb it it then goes to waste
and you create urine which is more
important inhaling or exhaling okay this
is important inhale
inhaling oryx
honestly as important it is to inhale I
think the exhale is the underrated
because you can really get a lot from an
exhale I don't want to go too spiritual
with it but it cleanses the soul and
essentially when you're inhaling you're
getting oxygen yeah okay good stuff but
when you're exhaling
carbon dioxide
CO2 c-o-o-l
cool
wait does Dr Mike have a Discord there
are Discord icons on some of these
questions yeah I have a Discord baby
join the patreon you get automatic
invite to the Discord and the patreon is
10 bucks a month I keep none of the
money each month you vote where that
money goes to the charity of your choice
we have a monthly live stream we always
have fun you get early access to tickets
to merch by the way merch Down Below
have you kept up your diet after your
last boxing match for this from it in
fact someone from the Discord sent me a
chocolate bar I ate the whole chocolate
bar just now I'm not proud of it but I'm
human and I make mistakes and this was
today's mistake why does cutting my hand
with scissors hurt less than a paper cut
oh that's such a good question first of
all I don't think that's true just
saying as a doctor I think just a paper
cut is less expected like if scissors
are cutting you you expect large amounts
of paint so you kind of prepare for it
but just like getting a hit unexpectedly
like getting Sucker Punch or something
hurts much worse a paper cut you're like
oh this is a paper no big deal oh
that uh cubby moment could be an issue
our pain perception is not solely
decided by the injury but also our
perception of the injury we basically
have like a volume remote of our pain
signals but if we can learn to dial down
the volume on the pain we can get a
better control of it without taking
medications I love the smell of scented
candles please tell me is there any
health benefits to them or do they just
smell good well they just smell good but
when you look good and you smell good
you might feel good and there's health
benefits to feeling good I don't know
why I just went Matthew McConaughey on
that what would happen if you got dust
in your bloodstream okay she'll be Dusty
I don't know your macrophages would
probably eat it I don't know you ask a
pathology channel is seltzer water
unhealthier than Flat Water oh man the
reality about sparkling water is the
only population of people that I say
should be careful with sparkling water
are people who have acid reflux because
if you already have some acid leaking
outside the gut into the esophagus
having bubbles in there you could
actually expand the stomach more and
cause more of that leaky gut especially
with burping and stuff then everything
else it's kind of not so bad it might be
slightly more acidic than tap water
especially if it has some like
flavorings in it but dentists say like
if you drink it with a meal or if you
drink some water right after it like
plain water you're fine if you're
replacing soda like sugary soda with
Seltzer dang right it's good for you is
Dr Mike expecting a child because these
dad jokes are getting out of hand
I'm having a baby
I don't have a good dad joke for that
but I am expecting
expecting you to laugh at these dad
jokes
I saved that one Lord now 72 asks is it
too late to get my flu shot well I'm not
exactly sure when this kit question came
in but as of answering this question
right now no it's not too late you can
still go get your flu shot that's
actually one of the reasons I was so
excited to partner with Walgreens who
offer online and same day scheduling for
vaccinations like updated covid-19
boosters flu shots and so much more
staying healthy during the cold winter
months can be tricky because of the
chilly air that can dry out your mucous
membranes which leads to damage where
viruses and bacteria can enter the body
your lips your nose getting these
vaccines is not only important to me
because I want to stay healthy but also
because I see many people who are
immunocompromised so getting my shots
helps them stay safer too Walgreens
pharmacists have safely administered
over a hundred million vaccines in the
last three years they're professional
friendly and available to answer all
your vax questions as well as provide
guidance on which ones you may need get
started on walgreens.com schedule
vaccine by booking your covid-19 booster
and flu shot appointments now are there
any benefits to having one blood type
over another outside of the ability to
donate we have seen some patterns about
certain illnesses happening less and
more often in certain blood types but
nothing that we found that we can really
act upon first of all what useful
information is that for you you're not
going to change your blood type maybe
you can change your certain activities
around certain things because you know
you're more susceptible but are you you
know being on your phone isn't that
healthy I see you doing a little risk
reduction though watching a doctor and
stuff answer medical questions so you're
growing up here but I see you how many
times a year do you encounter a live
animal in the hospital
live at me you mean like besides the
supporting pause program with like dogs
I mean like flies are they animals is a
fly a fly animal Sam fly would be an
insect but is that an animal I believe
insects are animals are they
it's actually the most diverse group of
animals uh-huh we call it you insects
how do you clean Bear's ears I actually
have a full grooming video where I groom
bear for like five hours I use like
these ear wipes these medicated ear
wipes I think it does a great job
there's also things that you can put in
the ear kind of Squish the ear around
and then let bear shake his ear out to
get the Liquid out oh wow you pronounced
bilmania correctly you really are
Russian yeah he's my favorite food sucks
or some oh oh my mother told me to never
stretch in the morning or I will stop my
growth is she telling the truth say what
right it's good I'm not a huge fan of
stretching cold I like stretching after
a little bit of a dynamic warm-up see
you might have a medical condition and
your mom back to this doctor doesn't
know you're talking about because you
have this medical condition say what for
the general person you stretch in the
morning props what kind of music does Dr
Mike listen to what is your Spotify rap
say I will give you three of my songs on
my Spotify wrapped
2022. song number One Mount Everest
which was my walkout song to my boxing
Journey with idubbbz number two city of
gods mostly because of Alicia Keys
singing up New York and then last but
not least a little sticky with Drake if
you know you know is it unhealthy for me
to never take my bra off I wear 24 7
because I'm uncomfortable when I have it
on 24 7 I would say is probably
unnecessary if something's bothering you
pain wise definitely a reason to see
your doctor even if you're younger
because it's easy enough to get an
ultrasound and make sure that it's
nothing serious remember I would much
rather you come in with a concern we not
only rule out anything dangerous
therefore we give you some reassurance
but then we also can make sure that we
have a good line of communication we can
give you some risks things that you're
doing that may be unhealthy that could
cause problems down the line and act
early there's very few things we can act
early upon but if we use the tools that
we have we can really extend not only
the length of our lives but the quality
of Our Lives why are an over-the-counter
medication dosages based on weight
they're only based on whether you're a
kid or an adult well it matters more
when you're a kid weight-based dosages
as an adult you have a healthy liver and
kidney so that like you have normal
functioning organs there's also a really
important takeaway Plan B a medication
that you use as emergency contraception
may not work as well and those are who
are over a certain number of pounds so
please be aware of that and speak to
your doctor about that situation I've
seen people not know that and then make
some bad decisions or at least incorrect
decisions about their health I know
under sleeping is bad for my health but
what about oversleeping if I sleep too
much can it be harmful sometimes I sleep
in late and somehow feel more tired
that's actually a classic thing and I
talked about it with Matthew Walker on
my podcast where if you're making up
sleep debt where you haven't slept for
certain number of nights in a row the
adequate numbers of sleep and then you
finally get a good night's sleep that
initial few minutes of waking up you're
gonna feel terrible because of sleep
inertia where you haven't yet kind of
cleared that sleep debt and you probably
need to sleep a few more nights in order
to start feeling better I heard if
you're having breakouts on your forehead
it's because of bad gut health is this
true and how can I improve my gut health
okay I'm going to take the second part
of the question first you can improve
your gut health by focusing on the
things we talk about quite often this
channel eating fibrous Foods those are
basically prebiotics eating a wide
variety of plants AKA fruits and
vegetables limiting the amount of simple
sugars you consume because those things
can actually worsen gut health now let's
talk about acne on the forehead maybe if
you're eating a really unhealthy Diet
also having a really unhealthy lifestyle
and not sleeping and all these things
yeah you might get a breakout because of
a hormonal issue but changing just one
little aspect is not gonna to have a
drastic outcome on your skin you need to
think about all the variables in your
life and try and improve your lifestyle
as opposed to finding a hack here that's
not the secret what's the difference
between a first second and third degree
burn depth depth
first degree burns only affect the outer
layer of the skin second degree burns
affect outer and underlying layer of
skin and third degree burns affect the
Deep layers of the skin see I even had
to look that up even though the answer
was outer outer and inner or deep
med school that you shouldn't spend
hours memorizing because what ends up
happening is you learn a lot of useless
information you could look up real quick
and that's what the new generation of
medical student doctors should be
someone that knows a lot but knows
things that they can forget that they
can look up real quick because the ease
of information is right there at our
fingertips so for example a guidelines
change all the time when it comes to
screenings I try not to memorize those
because I know that at any moment I can
look it up and get the most up-to-date
info even if I know it cold I still look
it up because I want to be sure that I'm
giving you the best Healthcare advice
I answered questions on the street well
not at the street but in Central Park
and they asked me tough ones too huge
thanks to Walgreens for sponsoring this
video schedule an appointment online at
walgreens.com schedule a vaccine and as
always stay happy and healthy
foreign
[Music]